how is everybody having a good time so
we're down to our final two speakers
about 25 minutes we're going to be
joined on stage by the fantastic
president of Portugal but before then
we've got somebody pretty special over
the past three years our next speakers
actions against Google Apple and
Facebook among others have helped shape
the future of technology and in
September of this year
she was bestowed with vast new powers
and appointed to an unprecedented second
term as the --use competitions
commissioner but also overseeing EU
digital policy as executive vice
president
she's arguably one of the most
influential women in technology today
now armed with those vast new powers she
is here to tell us about the task that
still lies ahead in conversation with
Larry Siegel please give a huge web
Summit welcome to Marguerite the Steyr
it's the businesses who pay their taxes
the real guarantee of an innovative
future comes from keeping markets open
so that anyone
big small can compete to produce the
very best ideas because obviously this
is the global matter this is not about
Apple this is not about Android this is
about Google behavior for everyone to
participate in paying their fair share
not more not less a behavior that's
illegal for a dominant company we will
keep focusing keep analyzing keep
keeping an eye so that technology will
serve us and not serve itself
[Music]
[Applause]
it's super exciting to be here with you
what an extraordinary time to have the
role that you have someone I was I was
look doing some research and someone
said she will have more leverage than
anyone else in the world she's will be
the most powerful regulator of big tech
on the planet and I know you've expanded
your role now how are you feeling about
it let's get let's do the emotions first
like how does this feel well I would
have felt alone if it wasn't for this
because I you know they say that it it
takes a village to raise a child it
takes I think that it takes a community
like this actually to make tech serve
humans because this is what we're going
to do well it's certainly at a time when
I feel like technology and humanity is
clashing in a very interesting way you
know what would you say in this new role
or the expanded role is your most
important priority well the first party
would always be humans that's technology
should serve us and that we need humans
to understand what is going on to create
what is going on and to do that as a
community the challenges that we have to
make the tech community in itself the
user community much more diverse and and
also to reflect the world that we want
to live in because if you look at the
data we have but also the data that
we're missing to make that available to
have the necessary skills and sufficient
investment but at the bottom line of all
of this is that we may have new
technology but we do not have new values
dignity integrity humanity equality
that's the same yeah you've been known
to take on the big tech companies Patty
was just talking about some of those
Apple Amazon Google do you think I mean
have you witnessed them change do you
think they're actually changing
their behavior and if not what will will
it be more fines or do you think I know
back in the u.s. you have presidential
candidates talking about breaking them
up what do you think will actually make
them change well first of all they're
different they're different in their
approach they're different in their
approach to law enforcement they're also
different when they partner up because
we do that as well for instance when it
comes to fighting illegal content but if
I've seen change it is basically to have
even bigger ambitions if you look at new
Google services being launched if you
look at the Facebook Libre plans if you
look at the Apple streaming services you
see still bigger ambitions and this also
shows me that we have reached a phase
where a competition law enforcement can
only do part of the job we need to find
the right level of democracy framing
tech and say this is how you should
serve us I mean let's let's talk about
Facebook right a lot of controversy over
there cryptocurrency a lot of
controversy over Libra should it be
allowed to proceed given Facebook's
history and handling privacy well first
and foremost we're trying to figure out
what it is and we can do that we can
look at it even though it it doesn't
really exist yet but this is not just
for me as commissioner for competition
this is for the entire Commission
because we have questions not only about
tying of the Facebook product and the
payment product and the dominance of
Facebook but colleagues of mine they are
asking questions about money laundering
terrorist financing financial stability
you know all the things that may come
when you create a currency that is not
under the control of authority you go to
Silicon Valley and I've been covering
tech for a very long time you go to
Silicon Valley you are actually feared
in Silicon Valley I mean there's a total
filter bubble in Intex sometimes where
you hear the US government say a lot of
things use here the FTC put these fines
out there
the DOJ but but I think there's really a
fear that you'll come in and make real
changes do you think that US regulators
are afraid to really punish technology
companies I mean there's a really
interesting contrast between Europe and
America that may have been but what I
sense is a very renewed not only
interest but also engagement by US
authorities to start asking questions to
start engaging to start investigating to
say well maybe maybe there's an enforce
enforcer role for us here as well and
that is very very welcome
you know there's this ongoing debate at
Facebook going back to Facebook about
political ads I'm sure you guys are
speaking a lot about this twitter has
drawn a hard line on making the decision
to ban them Jack Dorsey has said he
won't allow political ads on the
platform Mark Zuckerberg says despite
the fact that they could be spreading
lies that it shouldn't be up to the tech
companies to judge what's true
essentially it's not their
responsibility I know you guys are
thinking oh you're thinking a lot about
this type of thing who do you think is
right well I think we have discussed in
depth at length in the real world what
we want to accept and what we will not
accept I simply do not understand why
that's it's not the same thing in the
digital world because this is something
that we have discussed and that's been
back and forth and it has taken us age
and we'll say well this is the framework
for political advertising this is the
framework for our democratic debates why
that should be any different in a
digital world I don't understand and the
second thing is that maybe we should do
even more because the risk is that we
completely undermine our democracy
democracy is supposed to take place in
the open where a political ads can be
fact-checked contradicted different
opinions can be offered it can be
supported but if it's only in your face
it's only between you and Facebook and
their micro targeting of who you are
that's not democracy anymore
that is just privatized de facto
manipulation of of who you're going to
vote for and democracy is supposed to
take place in the open so what I mean
since people listen to you in Silicon
Valley what would be your message to
Mark Zuckerberg well I of course listen
very very closely when Mac Zuckerberg
gives evidence in the hearings and the
u.s. democracies senator conquests
committees what what is inspiring is not
just what you say it's also what you do
he's an amazing creator of an amazing
company and if he himself put action
behind his words we would see change
rapidly and that would be very welcome
know what kind of action one you see
other companies they say as you
mentioned Twitter we will not have
political advertising that of course is
not the end of that story because you
may still have bots and through all the
farms and and all of that but it's an
important step forward where the company
shows but these are our values this is
what we believe in we are not just a new
a sort of stream of whatever comes here
we have values here and I'm not the CEO
of Facebook I'm not to judge but I think
the time has come where they should also
put action behind their words part of
your new role will be setting the agenda
for regulations regarding artificial
intelligence and we are most certainly
heading towards the future we're biased
AI could have it could certainly have
detrimental implications for humanity
how will you see your role to regulate
that what kind of regulations do you see
putting into place around that well it's
a very tricky so the first thing that
we'll do is of course to listen very
very careful carefully to stakeholders
everywhere but we also try to listen
fast because as we're speaking AI is
developing and that is wonderful because
I see no limits as to how artificial
intelligence can support what we want to
do as humans take climate change I think
we can be much more effective in
fighting climate change if we use
artificial intelligence I think we can
spare people for you know Oh for stress
for waiting time between having being
examined by a doctor and having the
result of that examination and maybe
also more precise results in doing that
so I think the benefits of using
artificial intelligence they are with no
limits but we need to get in in control
of sort of the the cornerstones so that
we can trust it that it has human
oversight and very importantly that it
doesn't have bias because if we accept
bias then we basically just take the
world we have right now and and we set
it in stone
you know I I was recently speaking to
someone who runs the Center for humane
technology and he was talking about the
AI recommendation models that are being
built by Google and Facebook and Twitter
and he was saying you know Lorri these
companies know more about us and our
doctors and our lawyers our priests
confessionals combined and he says which
means he thinks they should be treated
as fiduciary you know they should if
they're not acting in our best interest
then we should have class-action
lawsuits and that's the way we should
start protecting ourselves in the future
so is that something you think about I
mean are you considering any types of
laws or regulations that would make
platforms more accountable for what's on
their what's on their platform this is
part of my mission letter the
president-elect has asked me to take
charge of exactly this discussion and
figure out if we will push for a new
legislation to make people more
responsible but there are more ways to
deal with what you're referring to
because one thing is that we have you
could call that sort of digital citizens
rights the gdpr
but that doesn't solve the question of
how much data can be collected about you
and we also need better protection and
better tools to protect ourselves from
leaving a trace everywhere we go
because otherwise I don't think that
we're ready to be you know naked without
a gadget without our phones without the
things that we like but maybe we would
like to be much more able to choose what
kind of trays we would leave behind and
that side of the equation will have to
be part of the discussion as well how
can we be better protected from leaving
that trays of data that allows companies
to know so much more about any one of us
that we might even realize ourselves so
how can we I mean what does that
actually look like I think a lot of
people are frustrated at this point I
remember interviewing Zuckerberg during
Cambridge analytic and it was
unbelievable how little we knew about
what was happening so you know you and
the seat what does what does that look
like well first of all I myself am very
happy that I have digital rights my
problem is that I find it very difficult
to enforce them
the only real result of me reading terms
of conditions is that I get myself
distracted from wanting to read the
article that wanted me to tap terms and
conditions so we need that to be
understandable so they know what we're
dealing with and we need software and
services that will enable us not to
leave the same kind of trace but as we
would otherwise do but you know I'm a
kind of a liberal I really hope that the
market will also help us here because
it's not just for politicians to deal
with this it is in an interaction with
the market that we can find solutions
because one of the main challenges in
dealing with AI is of course that there
is a risk that we will regulate for
yesterday and then it's worth nothing at
what point do you think the big tech
companies should be broken up I know you
said that this is the last thing in the
toolbox or this isn't what you're
thinking of first but at what point
would you advocate for companies like
Facebook or Google to be broken up but
two different perspectives first from a
competition point of view you would have
to do something we're breaking up the
company was the only solution to the
illegal behavior to the damage that you
have have provoked and we don't have
that kind of case right now I will never
exclude that that could happen but so
far we don't have a problem that big
that breaking up a company it would be
the solution a second perspective is of
course sort of the size in itself but
the problem in in that debate is that
the people advocating it don't
I have a model as to how to do this and
if you know this story about the antique
kind of creature when you chopped out
one head I think 1 2 or 7 came up so
there is a risk that you do not solve
the problem
you just have many more problems and you
don't have a way of at least trying to
control it
so I am much more sort of in the line of
thinking that you should say that when
you become that big you get a special
responsibility because you are de facto
the rule setter in the market that you
own and we could be much more precise
about what that then entails because
otherwise there's a risk that the many
many many interesting companies they
have no chance of competing you're
recently talking about your plants to
act against companies dodging tax
obligations and countries where their
users live and you know they have lots
of user data but they don't exactly make
it clear how that data is monetized and
you said something that I thought was
really interesting you said one of the
things I've learned is that it is not
you searching Google it is google
searching you what did you mean by that
well it's if if there is an imbalance
between what you get and and what you
pay then very often you're the product
it is you who are being searched because
all the data that you leave behind
they make you part of the products so
whenever you make a small query
well that query is not just the window
into the internet it's also a window
into you and part of the amazing
technology that they hold is the
technology to not only predict what you
want but also to not you into in to
making choices that you may otherwise
have maids and you know one of the
reasons why I really love a good magic
show is that this is labeled you're
going to be manipulators because you
know this is a trick there is a card
somewhere in the sleeve there is
something happening you know and you
find that it is fun and you are amazed
and if that was its case all the time
that you know this is this is a
prediction we take all the dates they're
all the knowledge we have about you then
you would have a different relationship
but here at least for me I still have
this sense of this is the right answer
this is the truth I am presented with
and not a prediction about what I want
to do next what do you think as we head
into 2020 what do you think is the
biggest threat facing technology
if technology gets self-consumed and not
open to the many many many people who
have great ideas in Europe over the last
ten years has developed a vibrant
dynamic startup community with a lot of
also scale-up potential you see small
start-up you see the giant businesses
you see how how there is an appetite to
use digital technologies for all kinds
of different things if if tech sort of
gets something that is only embedded in
giant companies that is beyond our
democracies then I think we lose trust
in technology and part of of my mission
is that we built trust in technology by
making sure that we can reach for the
potential but we can also do something
to control the dark sides do you think
that's where we're headed oh I will I
will do my best but but with great teams
and a lot of determination I think that
our democracies can't find that kind of
solutions yes I have to ask this because
I mean he he talks about a lot of people
but spoke about you recently president
Donald Trump accused you of being the
person who hates the United States more
than anyone I have met so just I just
want to give you the opportunity really
quick
[Music]
what would be your response to the
President of the United States well then
he can only meet people that really
loves the US okay you know so going off
of that we have you have Donald Trump
saying you hate the US you've got Tim
Cook saying the judgment he gets Apple
was total political crap you're just
like this person who ruffles feathers
left and right some of the most powerful
companies and people in the in the world
I just be curious like where does this
come from where does this drive come
from I know you grew up in a very
religious family you just go up against
everyone are you ever fazed well
actually maybe the point was that my my
family is said my both parents are a
priest in the Danish Church but they
were never that religious what they were
were they were open for contradiction
and when I was very small I read and we
only had a weekly paper and my dad was
active in local politics and there was a
very very angry piece in that paper
saying that he was completely and
everything was wrong and he should never
and all of them and I was devastated and
my dad he was enthusiastic this was
exactly what he wanted to achieve that
someone contradicted him so I have been
taught that saying what you think doing
what you find to be the right thing when
people contradict you and disagree with
you that is not a mistake on error or
bad this is the way the world is so you
should be able to stand there and do
what you find to be the right thing
in the time
in the time I started covering startups
back in 2009 and a man was I an optimist
right I remember covering companies when
they were just coming up and things got
really complicated and I think there's a
lot of a lot of people are really
wondering about this time are we gonna
come out of this and this tech good or
bad and so I'd be curious because I go
back to what I said at the beginning of
this conversation which is what a
fascinating time to sit in the seat that
you sit in are you an optimist do you do
you think we come out of this this big
tech win back trust but yes I am an
optimist but this is because I think
that it's a it's a moral obligation
because pessimists you know they really
never get anything done because it's
worse tomorrow so why bother ok now
we're at a time so I think that's a good
way to end thank you so much well it was
a pleasure being here with you thank you
very very much
[Applause]
[Music]